روايه البلوجر هدير عاطف بلسان محاميها في
تفاعلكم هو ردد فعل وزير سوداني على
انقطاع الكهرباء خلال كلمه تفجر المنصات
ضحكا وانتقاده
وهاروميغن يفجران زوابع جديده هذه المره
في وثائقي على نتفليكس اهلا بكم
في تطورات جديده ومتسارعه في القضيه اللي
تناولناها امس في حلقتنا قضيه بلوجر
المصريه هدير عاطف واللي بعد ما طلعت
ولدتها في فيديو بتبكي وبتصرخ واعلنت
اختطاف من قبل بلطجيه
بنتها وطلع زوجها او طليقها مو عارفين لسه
ونشر سوريا
واعلنه القبض على بلوجر ازياء وشقيقه
زوجها وزوج شقيقه تبين انه هدير عاطف او
تبين ان فعلا هدير عاطف مثل ما توقعوا
الناس وبيانات داخليه يتكلم عن 16 مواطن
مقدمين شكاوى ضد هدير وزوجها واخته وزوجها
بيتهمه النصب والاحتيال
التطورات انه طلعت والده هدير عاطف ووضحت
الامور وكانت انه بنتها ضحيه بسبب طليقها
وملا اي ذنب وقالت انه هي ما كانت تعرف ان
الاشخاص اللي جوه واخذوا بنتها هم من
المباحث وانا فكرتهم الاشخاص اللي بيهددوا
بنتها من شهرين بسبب المبالغ الماليه اللي
اخذها زوجها او طليقها منهم وما رد لهم هي
ولا اعطاهم الارباح والنصب عليهم واكدت
انه بنتها بتعرف ايش بيشتغل زوجها ولما
عرفت انه بينصب على الناس طلبت الطلاق
والطلقت وكلام الام اكده مو حامل بلوجر
اللي كان طلع وقال له اللي تم القبض او تم
القاء القبض عليها هي هديل وانها ما لها
علاقه باللي جالس بيصير وانه تم القبض على
ثلاثه من المتهمين ولكن طليق هدير بلال
ديب لسه هربان امه وعارفين وينه ولكن في
نفس الوقت محاميات مجموعه من المجموعه
عليهم قالت انه هي من هرمشه في القضيه
ومعاها مستندات ووثائق بتثبت انه هدير طرف
فيه يعني عمليه النصب هذه وفي محادثه
بينها وبين هدير وبين بلال طليق هدير او
زوجها ما احنا عارفين لسه زي ما بقول لكم
وحوالات بانكيه والمنصات وسائل اعلام
مصريه بتتكلم ان الفلوس هذه اشترى فيها
الزوجين فيلا وفي كلام كمان عن سر وجمعها
بلال من العملات المشفره اللي ممنوع
التداول فيها في مصر وقيل انه رصيد وفيها
354 مليون دولار وكلام متفاصيل اخرى كثيره
مو معروف حقيقتها وعموما ومن اقل من ساعه
السلطات المصريه طلعت بيان اعلى ناس في
القبض على زوج هدير وحبسه هو واربعه اخرين
امرتنيابه القاهره الجديده بحبس زوج
البلوجر هذه العاطف اربع واربعه اخرين
اربعه ايام على ذمه التحقيق بتهمه النصب
والاحتيال على مواطنين طيب معانا عبر
الهاتف مح يا قلبي لوجر هدير عاطف الاستاذ
محمود السمري اهلا فيك معنا استاذ محمود
هل في عندك تفاصيل جديده على اللي ذكرنا
اليوم
تفضل استاذ محمود هل عندك في تفاصيل جديده
في القضيه هل تعلم هل في تحقيقات جديده
بتاريخ 25/11
الاستاذ محمود
قال لزوجها
ما هو البيان النيابه كان طالع على اساس
الحاله العامه اللي ظهر قدام الجميع
والراي العام اللي هي فعلا كانت زوجته لكن
الطلاق تم التاريخ 25/11 النيابه العامه
ما طلعت البيان طلعت البيان على الحاله
القائمه قدام الجميع هي ما كتبتش ان هي
قالت الحقيقه اللي هو زوجته ان احنا
امبارح قدمنا وثيقه طلائها بتاريخ 25/11
بس البيان النيابه كان طالع كانها لسه عدد
المترو طيب خلاص وضحنا هذه النقطه طيب فهي
طليقه
باريس 25/11 هي متوجه لها التهامات هي
واخته وجوز اخته بالاشتراك معاه النصب
والاستيلاء على الاموال من الناس بحجه
تشغيلها واستثمارها هي
هدير بلوجر عندها بلورز وصل ل 2200 2
مليون 600 بحكم شهرتها وزوجها برده بلوجر
بس مش بنفس شغلها بنفس شغل العريضه
الازياء ابتدا يشتغل في الاستثمار فهي
متهمه الاشتراك معه لكن هي طبعا انقرض حته
علمها ان هو بيستثمر فلوس الناس وياخذ
الفلوس
اللي مجني عليهم بتقول انه لا عندها ادله
علمها بالموضوع ومحادثات هم بالفعل قدمه
ما بينها وما بين بعض الضحك
الناس اللي هي دفعت فلوس لبلال زوجها لكن
كان كبرير وكبرينا اللي همم النهارده
زوجها فاي احد بيكلم زوجها تليفونه مقفول
كانت هي بترد على التليفون ردد على
التليفون خلي الناس تحس اللي هي شغاله
معهم لكن كان نوع من انواع الترويج لعمله
ده ما حصلش اكونت بتاعه تحت هيشغلها عريضه
ازياء ومسافه على حسابها ولا مره قالت انه
مثلا انا زوجي عنده هذا النوع من الخدمه
او انا او حطيت رقمه او اي شيء من هذا
القبيل
هي بتعمل شغلها لكن اللي بيتصل على تليفون
زوجها
يعني واحده ما تعرف نشاط زوجها
هي هي بتقول نشاط زوجها نشاط استثماري
استثمار في العقار والسيارات والبورصه هي
دي اللي عندها علم دي اكثر من كده هي ما
تعرفش اي حاجه عن حته اللي هو ممكن ياخذ
الفلوس ما يرجاش وبتفعل في بعض الضحايا
قالوا ان هم كانوا بياخذوا ارباح يعني حتى
امبارح في الطرقات قدام النيابه قبل ما
يخشوا كنا بيقولوا احنا اخذنا ارباح بس هو
توقف عن الارباح فهي زوج بها ليه زوج بيها
مش همم مكيده فيها لا هي تورطت في حته
اللي هي مشهوره وزوجها عمل كده وهرب اما
هرب ما فيش غيرها النيابه العامه
الطليق خلينا نسمي الامور مسميات عباءه
انه انت قلت انه طريقه
هل بدات تحقيق معه
هو غالبا النهارده لازم يتعرض لان
النهارده معنى اللي هدير اخذت 4 ايام على
ذمه التحقيق يبقى لازم تستقبل التحقيقات
معه لاني في الايام اللي جايه لازم يبقى
في مواجهات مع الضحايا وهو لازم النهارده
يتعرض اكيد بصدد العرض الان واخته وزوجها
دول تم التحقيق معهم امبارح واخذوا اربع
ايام
مستجدات تخصهم هل قالت هدير انهم على
الاطلاع بالموضوع
في الموظفين فابتدا يستخدم اخته وزوجها
والرد على بعض العملاء والتحويلات الفلوس
ما بينهم الى ومنهم منهم واله
على العموم احنا بنشكرك على هذه المداخله
وهذه التوضيحات واكيد خلال الايام القادمه
يعني هتتوضح الامور اكثر من كده نحن
بنشكرك على هذه المداخله كان معنا محامي
البلوجر هدير عاطف الاستاذ محمود السمري
شكرا لكم
اهلا من جديد من ايام طرح على نتفليكس
المسلسل الوثائقي هاري
بيتكلموا عن قصتهم ومليان مقابلات كمان مع
ناس من دائرتهم المقربه وبيعرض صوره
فيديوهات ما عرضت من قبل ونتفليكس حاطه
على المسلسل
فوق ال 16 سنه والسبب اللغه اللي شايفينها
مو مناسبه لمنهم اقل عمرا
يبقى فاهمه
[تصفيق]
تفضل شويه
[موسيقى]
الاعلان اللي شفتهم لما نزل قلب الدنيا
انتقادات وغضب من الثنائي اللي بيدعوا
امتلاكهم الحقيقه ومع طرح اول ثلاثه حلقات
الهجوم والغضب زاد واكثر واكثر والعالم
بانتظار الثلاث حلقات المتبقيه والمنتظر
طرحها بعد بكره ولو حنستعرض سريعا بعد
النقاط المستفزه الناس فممكن نذكر منا
سريعا كم وحده الكلام عن التمييز بسبب
العراق تشبيه ميجانا المستمر بالاميره
ديانا واللي تعرضت له والخوف عليها من
مصير مشابه كلام عن تهديدات بالقتل هجوم
على العائله المالكه وكلام من هاري انه
العيله كذبت عشان تحمي اخوه وما حاولت
تحميه تصريح من ميجل انه تم اطعامها
للذئاب هذه حيينه بسيطه من قنا بالفجروها
الثنائي في هذا الوثائق الهجوم والجدل
واسعين لدرجه في تسريبات من القصر عن رده
الفعل المصدومه من الانجال في الوثائق
وزير الخارجيه البريطاني طلع رد ونفل
اتهامات بالعنصريه عن العائله المالكه
والثنائي نفسهم طلعوا بيان على لسان
المتحدث باسمهم ردوا فيه على الهجوم
والانتقادات تحديدا من الناس اللي قالوا
لهم انتم مشيتوا من العيله الملكه علشان
الخصوصيه والانجاسين بتعملوا مسلسلاته
وثائقيه رد الثنائي كان انه عمرهم ما
قالوا انه بحثهم عن الخصوصيه كان السبب
وراء اعتزالهم العمل العام وللاسف هذه مو
اول مره بيسببوا ازمه بسبب كلامهم عن
العائله المالكه فمن يوم ما تركوا العائله
الملكه والامور بتتده وارجع لسا وبدات
بتسريبات وبعدين مقابله في الكارثيه طبعا
شهيره جدا والكثير من الاحداث من بعدها
والان هذا الوثائقي كمان هذا غير طبعا
مذكرات هذه المنتظره واللي يتوقع انها
تعمل جد مو اقل من اللي صاير حاليا ابدا
ينضم الينا من لندن الصحفي المختص في شؤون
العائله المالكه البريطانيه النيل جون
اهلا فيك همم معنا النيل الحقيقه ثانيه
يعني ما اعرف من فين ابتدي لكن خلينا
نبتدي من ال- ال- ال- الهدف العام ماذا
يريد هاري هل يريد تدمير عائلته
من لندن وشكرا جزيلا على استضافتي خلاصه
القول هي ان المساله لا تتعلق بتدمير
الاسره الملكيه بل تتعلق
بالاموال الطائله التي تم دفعها من اجل
انتاج هذا الفيلم وكان لابد من تقديم
برنامج مناسب ان جعل هاري بهذه الصوره
بانه قد قدم جمله من الاكاذيب هذا امر غير
مناسب اذا لم نكون متاكدين فلا يجب ان يتم
مثل هذا الام يدعونا ان تذكر ان ما قالته
سيد مارجريت سابقا للمحاكم البريطانيه حيث
قالت بانني لست همم
هذه القصص اللي تنتازيه عن ان المساله
للملاحقه وكذلك هاري ما صرح بهذه الامور
لا باس لكن اعلم ان مشاهديكم كل هذه امور
ولا وقد يصعب وتزقها خلاصه القول ان بعض
الوثائقيات مثل التي حدثت في السبعينيات
والثمانينيات قد تكون وهي النسخه مشابهه
لما نراه وهذا الوثائقي يخلو من الحقائق
والوقائع لاننا لا يمكن ان نتعلقه لا يمكن
ان نذكر كل ما حدث في هذا الوثائق ويرتبط
بحياتهم الفعليه هذا الوثائق طبعا اهميه
تكمل فانه هم الاثنين جالسين بيتكلموا في
في واحده من الاشياء اللي لعبوا كثير
عليها ويتكلموا كثير عليها موضوع العنصريه
والعرق
والوثائق عرض تاريخ بريطانيا في العنصريه
واا تحرير العبيد وكل ما الى ذلك يعني هل
تشعر انه من المنصف انه يتم استعراض
التاريخ باكمله في وثائق بهذا الشكل عنهم
15.5
للسخريه في اي بلد في العالم لديها تاريخ
تاريخ سيء وتاريخ جيد
واذا ما كنتم ترغبون بدراسه التاريخ لا
يجدر بكم مشاهده
في ال ال في القصر وحظيه بحمايه امنيه
كبيره هذه
المعاملات التي
وكاميرات العالم
ولا يمكن لاي شخص ان يتحدث عن العنصريه
قدر من الاموال واذا ما حصل على هذه
الاموال فلماذا يتوجب عليهم البقاء في
القاصر
طيب ماذا عن الربط المستمر بين ااه اا
ميغان
والاميره ديانا الاميره الراحله الديانه
حتى من قبل هاري نفسه بيتحدث انه لديها
شخصيه امه بانها بتذكره بامه بانه خايف
عليها من مصير امه
رائعا من الامير هاري
لتشبيه زوجته بوالدته تلك المراه الرائعه
التي تحلت بصفات الدماثه والطيبه هذه مره
اخرى هي ضرب من الاكاذيب لا يمكن ان يربط
زوجته بوالدته التي تعدوا معروفه في
المجال العام وقد لا يكون مدركا مثلا
بتاريخ الملكيه
لو كنا نعلم عن الامير
ان يتحدث عنها بهذه الطريقه
اللي فجر مفاجاه كبيره لا يمكن وضعهما في
بوتقه واحده ابدا
اذا تقلنا على نقطه معينه اللي هي نقطه
استفزت كثير من الناس وتحديدا اللي هي اول
مقابله بين ميغان والملكه الراحله
اليزابيث عندما تحدثت انه كيف هي انحنت
امامها ومثلتها بطريقه مبالغ فيها وضحكت
وسخرت وهو حتى ما علق هذه النقطه ازعجت
كثيرين يعني انا مش بريطانيه وانا بتفرج
حسيت انه هو ليه بيتكلم وكده على الملك
الراحل لانه الموضوع فيه نوع من الاهانه
فما بالك من بريطانيين كيف شعرته
يوسف يوسف
على ذلك اشكرك على هذا الامر لان اناس كثر
كانوا قد شعره ان تم نوع من الاهانه من
خلال هذا التحرك ولا سيما بانه لا يوجد
معامله الملك وانا كنت قد عملت في حلقه
الضيقه لسنوات طويله وهذا شرف كبير
بالنسبه لي الامر
يجب ان يذكرنا بان تدعي بانها ممثله
وبانها قد استلهمت بما قد بافلامها كثيره
وكان يجدر بها ان تظهر نوعا من الدماثه في
حديثها عن الراحل الملكه كذلك يمكن
تماما من هذا الامر
ايضا قوه
تسبب هذا الامر بازعاج كبير للالاف همم
معناها لاتنا والشعب البريطاني لن يتقبل
مثل هذا الامر ولا اعتقده للحظه واحده
بانه يمكن قبولي هذا الامر ولسيما بالنسبه
لتحالفهما معا وهذا سوف يشكر نقطه سوداء
في الحديث عن التاريخ البريطاني وعن الملك
الراحل بهذه الطريقه
تستمر خصوصا انه طالما هناك مقابل مادي
ستزيد القصص بنشكرك على هذه المداخله كان
معنا الصحفي المختص في شؤون العائله
المالك البريطانيه
[موسيقى]
في مقطع فيديو لوزير الماليه السوداني
جبريل ابراهيم وضعوا في موقف محرج جدا
خلال الجلسه الافتتاحيه لمجلس الوحده
الاقتصاديه العربيه في الخرطوم امس
السودان
لا محدوده
المتاحه في الزراعه والثروه الحيوانيه
وتصنيع الزراعي والبنيه التحتيه المرتبطه
بسلاسل الامداد الغذائيه
نزلنا
سوا
الفضي
[موسيقى]
على الله
وخصوصا رده فعل الوزير لمن سواء سال سؤال
الناس دول فضائح ما عندهم جنريتر والوزير
من بعد ما جاءت الكهرباء بعد دقائق معدوده
استغل هذه الفرصه وحاولي تتدارك الموقف
اللي صار ودعم المستثمرين اللي حاضرين
المجلس الاقتصاد العربي انه تكون الكهرباء
احد القطاعات المستهدفه للاستثمار خلال
المرحله المقبله لكن حتى هذا النداء
محاولاته تدارك الموقف ما حمى الوزير من
الانتقادات والتعليقات اللي طلبته بسبب
الفيديو
على فكره بس للتفكير يعني يبدو انه وزير
الماليه مره محظوظ خلال كلماته والكاميرات
جاهزه دائما تلقط له ردات فعله فمن فتره
كان له مشهد وردت فعل ثانيه صارت برضو حتى
تكلمنا عنه خليني اذكركم فيها
61 الدرجه اسمعني
رد علي بالتالي
خلاص
[موسيقى]
حلقه اليوم